across the broad expanse of history
there have been billions upon billions
of idiots as well as a handful of smart
people we interviewed some of the latter
group for our ongoing series great minds
people who think good
this week's people who thinks good
Stephen Hawking international
best-selling author and a popular guest
character on The Simpsons
yeah just trying to use his breakthrough
work on black holes and string theory is
considered hugely important by anyone
who pretends to understand it an
expanding universe does not preclude our
creator I traveled to the Department of
Applied Mathematics and theoretical
physics at Cambridge University to speak
with one of the world's greatest living
minds first off congratulations on being
the first subject of our great mind
series be honest is this the single
greatest honor you have ever received
yes good it's a little hard to read your
tone of voice when you say that are you
being sarcastic yes if there is one
thing you want people to understand
about your work bearing in mind that
most people will never understand
anything about your work what would that
thing up against a deadline but it's a
well-defined concept the imaginary time
is like another direction in space it's
the one bit of my work science fiction
writers have used because they don't
understand it
idiots people are such idiots because
presumably to my mind you're simply
talking about the theoretical
measurement obtained from real time by a
wink rotation of pi divided by two in
the complex
plain wet T equals I times T she's not
that difficult to get your head around
let's talk about artificial intelligence
in a recent op-ed column you said and I
quote success in creating artificial
intelligence would be the biggest event
in human history unfortunately it might
also be the last are you saying that
robots are going to destroy humanity and
is that a scientific argument or the
pitch for an amazing movie I know you're
trying to get people to be cautious
there but why should I not be excited
about fighting a robot I couldn't then
just unplugging in so it could be turned
off holy that's the most terrifying
story I've ever heard
hold on who is talking to me right now
is it you or is the sentient computer
pretending to talk on your behalf yeah
but how do I know that professor because
if computers had become sentient what
better way to convince people they
hadn't then by co-opting the voice of
the most intelligent man on the planet
[Applause]
okay alright with that
that's actually quite reassuring you
stated that you believed there could be
an infinite number of parallel universes
does that mean that there is a universe
out there where I am smarter than you
if you're so smart what number am I
thinking of
today what it was 13 or what I was
thinking of 13 okay that was a lucky
guess what am I thinking right now I
wasn't thinking that what would I think
that you know I'm trying as hard as I
can
why is that so hard for them to
understand quite effectively or what I'm
thinking that let's do some quick yes or
no questions are the following things
technically possible life on other
planets is that theoretically possible
yes
okay what about a Schwarzschild wormhole
yes okay what about this me going on a
date with Charlize Theron in no universe
in none of the infinite universes does
that happen it's completely beyond the
bounds of scientific possibility is what
you're saying yes quick follow-up
question in any of those potential
universities and either one rejecting
her and that's why it doesn't work out
okay sure yeah it's just I'm trying to
play this out because it just I just
trying to see if there was any
hypothetical hole it doesn't matter but
never say never okay if time travel were
possible would you want to go back in
time and refused to do this interview
yes
you truly are an incredibly smart man
Stephen Hawking thank you so much for
your time